Let's talk a little bit about
the processing of video and
some of the applications or
not just applications, but
the general computations
that we would want to do.
And then we could talk about how
motion could be used in order to,
or the motion processing
be used to do that.
So, a simple one is
background subtraction.
So you might have a situation where
you've got a static camera and
a the background is considered
to be a static background and
I've got some object
moving in the foreground.
And my goal is to pull out
the foreground object,
the moving thing from
the static background.
So, I may be able to track it or
model its dynamics or recognize it or
something else that's,
that's focused on the object.
Another interesting application might
be what we call shot detection and
that's illustrated here.
So the idea is here we have a bunch
of frames that are in a video and
commercially produced video is usually
made up of a sequence of shots,
each shot coming from
a particular camera.
The camera might be moving,
it might be panning.
It might be dallying moving, translating
and then you'll cut to a different shot.
And in this particular case,
our shot boundary is shown right here.
Right?
All of these are taken from one camera
shot and these are taken from another.
Often, it looks to you like they're
taken one right after another.
But in reality, they changed everything.
They moved the camera around,
changed the actor.
Redid his makeup,
he went and got a smoke or
whatever it is they're smoking on set.
And then they came back and
they did the, the next shot and
they just cut them together.
And if you think about what that would
look like to a computer in one case,
I might have a nice, smooth background
moving with some objects moving within
it and then there's this rapid change
and I might have another camera,
which might not be static,
it might be moving as well.
And the analysis of that motion might
allow you to do the shot detection.
So we have background subject,
subtraction,
we have shot boundary detection.
Maybe we have a bunch of objects that
are moving in different ways within
a scene and we'd like to separate
out each of those objects and
that's referred to as
motion segmentation.
Motion segmentation is you
segment the video into multiple,
what we call coherently moving objects.
All right?
So they're each moving, but
they're moving in an independent way.
So here's an example.
And what's funny is this is a static
image of a snake and a mongoose taken
off the web and you could imagine trying
to separate these out just spatially.
In fact, you can sort of do that.
But in fact,
the color of the mongoose and
the snake is very similar to
the color of the background.
And if you were to track these things,
you would see pixels coming and going.
But if you actually were
to look at the motion,
you would see the motion of the snake
as being a coherent thing and
the motion of the mongoose as
being a coherent thing and
you would be able to use motion
to segment out those objects.